uh oh here's a good one what does it
mean when she puts it's complicated on
her profile that that usually means one
of one of several things uh could be
that she's still living with her
boyfriend because the release hasn't
expired or they're waiting to sell the
condo could mean she's living with her
husband
could mean uh any number of things but
what it really means is she's going to
complicate the out of your life if
you invite her into it so if you see
it's complicated friends with benefits
that's it until the complication or the
entanglement remember the whole will
smith jada pinkett smith thing the
entanglement it's complicated same
you know when the complicated situation
goes then you might want to look at her
but the whole you know it's complicated
don't waste too much time on it yeah
it's high drama exactly
uh it's complicated she's looking for a
next victim yet is still with uh the one
and hasn't broken off with the current
one yeah essentially what i said earlier
it's um
she's a monkey brancher
it's it's complicated means that she
still lives with somebody or there's
something going on where she can't
uh unshackle herself from it yet
uh
boom boom yeah i got yours moff it's
complicated equals in the process of
monkey branching yep just cover that the
guy likely doesn't know it's complicated
this is uh essentially uh true i would i
would co-sign that more often not dude
usually doesn't know how complicated it
is that she's with right now
um
so like it's complicated for the guy out
of the loop and more trouble than what
it's worth for you yeah
uh i've seen a huge uptick in
ethically non-monogamous on the apps
lately and generally they're gross women
um they're not hot women
um
it's it's
it's gonna be like the left or leaning
purple hair short haircut face pierced
crowd
you know with bumper stickers all over
them tattoos um in random places
so yeah you will see that cool you know
whatever
they're just
all that really means is that they're
openly being hypergamous and saying that
they're open to the best option they
could possibly get what that usually
means is she's probably with one or two
dorks right now and is looking for an
alpha chad that she can spend the
weekends on that's usually what it means
when you see ethically non-monogamous it
means that they know that she's going to
go out and bang a chat and they have to
be okay with it
it's open on their end too but they
never get any new play from any other
ladies and they're paying the rent
they're paying for the food they might
be raising um you know some other dudes
kids or or several of them you know in
some cases uh while she goes out looking
for some chad to rearrange her guts and
that's generally you know the you know
the hot dudes that are going to be on
the dating apps that's where they come
from
uh i went on a date with a sorry i went
out on a date in my mid-20s with a girl
who lost her license from a dui
didn't do a second date yeah that's good
choice
i haven't worked out since high school
yeah that's like 10 pounds that's a lot
more than 10 pounds only speaking
uh educated girls are often the dumbest
bunch of the girls you'll meet legit
smarkles don't have to signal that
they're smart exactly you know people
that are something don't need to
state it you know i'm you know like i'm
interesting
okay well why do you need to state that
people know the minute she opens her
mouth to speak
absolutely
i mean like you can generally tell by
the photography that's being used so
it is what it is
worthless degree bachelors of arts
philosophy
feminist studies female studies any any
number of those things basket weaving
underwater basket weaving
let's see what else we got here hey
bubblies or bubblies
she has two nopes stranger danger
just looking to see if i missed anything
here that might women think attention
equals love
is it possible to find a viable female
in today's world yes it is absolutely
possible but you are going to have to
dig through a hell of a lot of dirt to
find gold
um
the book of numbers
mr cleary wrote that and he concluded
somewhere between i think it was about
three percent of women are going to be
worth your while
on a long term basis so three to five
percent is what i would say
um you can increase that slightly if
you're a top shelf guy you know like one
of the one percent
as far as looks money status captivation
you know you've got things interesting
going on in your world you know you got
your life sorted basically um
it is entirely possible but it's gonna
be a heck of a lot of work like i said
you're gonna have to dig through a lot
of dirt to find gold and the starting
place for you guys again read the damn
book
the unplugged alpha helps set your set
your mind in the correct direction
if that's what it is you're looking for
you